oops oops I like him to this video
playing Benjamin bleak break no flag and
the goon fraud okay let's play another
sideline this recently has been played a
couple of times and it seems to be a
quite decent way to play without
studying so much um goon fault theory
leads to a fairly typical position for
this opening
I just got this um this deep on some
black has a nice bishop on g7 and active
active pieces okay so probably just
develop look g one moves like that
support the pawn and i'd like to play
Bishop h6 at some point yeah let's try
to exchange it or Falls it to some
square doesn't really want to go to k
can i play oh no i don't i cannot
thought f4 maybe 4g for like very active
not good okay let's prevent be five for
the moment
hmm
yeah piece on getting something to do
three not good
not good at all
hmm yeah I don't like it 24 I thought 94
is a trick yeah on b3 he unfortunately
has screen before yeah okay not not
enjoying this move Bishop t3 domain
taking only three it's not a movement
like to play yeah quite uncomfortable
mmm 94 94 25 9 f 6 yeah this isn't bad I
can just take it at play Bishop h2 I
just blundered blunder to PCM oops you
could have just taken it check
yeah very lucky bad bad game mummy this
would have been a very easy win for him
now I have from this long diagonal that
I can try to use I have a very very good
compensation now if he takes Queen takes
on threatening queen deform and maybe I
also have rook g3 rupee one yeah let's
let's see
ya hice push-up is just just a very bad
PCM so I'm just doing nothing
essentially okay get rid of this I need
to the Queen into play of course hmm how
to do that
I don't see how to our camp it doesn't i
don't i don't really need to to win this
game I mean can just exchange they
having pieces and and draw
opposite kind of Bishop son and game
would be complete draw but you know
maybe I'm I have something in queen of
six Queen HOH HOH hey I don't think H
falls particularly great it's just a
liability to spawn
very uncomfortable for black
I don't really see a clear way to draw
here for black
I don't I don't see what you should do a
queen F successor is a big big threat
and he also has no perpetual or anything
I don't see what I think it's it's maybe
it's just winning up cooing here maybe
no that's okay let's just let's just do
that ok so this check it's not to
winning I can play this smooth black
king edge 5 Queen g5 mate and King h7 I
take a check f7 and made yeah I probably
was too optimistic i think you really
should play check should try to draw
check with optimal color designs it's
it's very tricky already of course I
should have lost the game simply because
this is a blunder you can you can just
just take it here a channel I resign so
more than lucky and here i was
completely outplayed go check with this
this already is very good compensation I
think don't think white should lose this
anymore simply also because of the pawn
configuration with the bishop on f3 I
always keep the Queen side completely
blocked and he needs to exchange heavy
pieces I think to draw especially I've
course the Queen's ok this is yeah
something like let's say something like
like this maybe I don't know covering
those squares yeah it's this is a kind
of position when blitzer white is just
easier to play you always have those
ideas and black and basically do nothing
to be active and he blundered at the end
of course very lucky I could have played
Bishop h2 and I really played played
this bad layout right out of the opening
around here so a six and A royalty I
need to do something else not quite sure
what maybe d6 on the way it did it
italia did went down it was it was
excellent fun so maybe Matt maybe maybe
something else here this is this is not
good at all also weakening me form yeah
maybe something like that I know a bad
black is okay probably this line doesn't
show much promise so much okay thanks
for watching